il a tous les samedis sont
systématiquement pas systématiquement
bien sûr tout assez intuitif c'était
quand un instant quand
ça nous prend une folie ya rien de
systématique et ensemble dans la vie oui
oui on vit ensemble depuis dix ans ah
ouais 50 qui dure ah oui oui oui on
pratique le club quand même temps en
temps mais elle vous croyez que si vous
pratiquez pas ce genre de sport vous
seriez plus ressemble le plus de poids
aux je pense je pense que c'est une
question de complicité c'est une
complicité
on n'est pas arrivé à fréquenter les
clubs comme ça en une fois c'est venu
petit à petit on a un petit peu plus
loin à chaque fois ça a commencé par
des exhibitions très très légère au
début je tairai petit à petit un peu
plus loin un peu plus loin et puis après
on essaie de faire des petits contrats
me et puis après on vient dans les clubs
je vais pas tenter d'être plus en plus
loin si si constamment constamment sain
et sauf et papa n'ont pas su bon on a
quand même des limites des limites
ouais on s'est fixé des limites et
maison que j'arrivais à baiser
normalement oui oui parce que c'est une
question de stimulus que c'était qu'on
est tout ce qu'on fait là ce soir ça va
nous c'est gravé dans nos mémoires pour
vos longtemps quoi donc ça ça fantasme
quoi ça me permet d
des folies quand on rentre c'est encore
pire d'ailleurs fait vachement final
vous trompez pas finalement non parce
qu'on
france en enfer en fait tous ensemble
voilà rien séparer ça que je pourrais
pas concevoir qu'elle s'en aille avec un
homme ou une femme samsam j'aimerais
quelque part et quand je suis là y'a
aucun problème qu'est-ce que tu y avait
le plus envie au départ ouais parce que
je suis déjà plus âgées
déjà je suis âgée j'ai en la disant 13
ans d'écart donc moi j'avais une vie
déjà un petit peu petit peu dissolue
blain peut déjà donc quand je les
rencontre et je les amenais sais pas non
je connaissais pas du tout c'est une
petite jeunette
elle est connue elle avait 18 ans sage
message vous regrettez pas et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou